welcome
to this free webinar on omix logic data
science
in today's session our team will be
sharing
information examples and an overview of
omix logic training resources
designed for anyone to learn data
science for biomedical data
as seen in application to projects
sourced from current topics in
biomedical research
in this webinar we will introduce
biomedical
data analysis techniques and approaches
that you can master
and adopt to help you conduct better
research
and learn about how data science is
changing
medical research from diagnosis to
treatment selection
and development of new therapeutics
my name is beepsha biswas and i am the
omixlogic community manager
responsible for daily interaction with
thousands of users
that are a part of our bioinformatics
community
managed by buying biotech now before
i move on i
want to ask you to take this poll which
you can now see
on your screens
the first question of this poll is what
country
are you from you can choose from this
list
i hope everyone can see the poll on the
screen
you can put it in the poll if you do not
see your country listed you can put that
down
in the chat box thank you so much kony
and abdullah for
letting me know and athera i see that
you cannot hear any sound you can leave
the zoom meeting and join back again
with
zoom audio that would be helpful
okay we have a lot of participants from
india
and there are a lot of other countries
which i can see
so lydia is from malta with all from
brazil
abeed is from malaysia franco javier is
from peru
iraq brazil so we have a lot of
participants from
different parts of the world and if we
move on to the second question it is
what is your level of
education the first is high school the
second is bachelor's degree
third master's degree phd and then there
are other degrees
which you may have taken
you can just select the
answer that is suited to yourself
thank you ashwini for letting us know
the third answer question is your area
of
interest so you can choose between these
different datas bioinformatics
biotechnology cell in molecular biology
computer science data science
infectious diseases oncology and
others
this poll is going to help us learn more
about our audience today
and the last question is what are you
expecting to get
from this webinar today so are you
looking forward to learn more about data
science learn about introduction to
machine learning tools
learn about bioinformatics programming
in r and python
or acquire new skills
so i'll keep the poll on for about
another minute and we will then continue
with today's session
okay so thank you everyone
for voting and for sharing your answers
with us
thank you harsh for sharing
about your interest and ashwini as well
thank you dr deena
so i will be ending the poll now and if
you have
any other answers or if you want to
share with us you can please put your
answers down in the chat box
so moving on
i would like to start by introducing
pine biotech the company behind
omix logic and share with you details
about the upcoming omics logic programs
and explain how the training resources
we will discuss today will be used in
this data science program
so omics logic is a program for
bioinformatics training
that was developed in collaboration
between pine biotech and the tower
bioinformatics research center
what we will discuss today is a result
of hard work by an
amazing team led by company co-founders
dr alfred tober and dr leonid rotsky
dr alfred tober comes from a medical
background
and has extensive expertise in oncology
immunology
and biochemistry of inflammation and has
been recognized internationally for his
generous support of
many research projects and initiatives
that support data science training and
applications in medicine
dr leonid brodsky is the director of the
tauber bioinformatics research center
at university of haifa and is an expert
in bioinformatics and biostatistics he
has numerous publications in mathematics
and bioinformatics
and over the course of his career has
developed
multiple novel algorithmic approaches to
biomedical data analysis
the rest of the team you see here
includes experts in bioinformatics
computer science and training and some
of our team will be presenting today as
well
over the course of the past several
years our team has been collaborating
with a number of academic institutions
around the world
that have participated in content
evaluation curriculum review
and project design as a result the omics
logic programs have been thoroughly
evaluated and are known to lead to
excellent outcomes
importantly the programs are designed to
support students with minimal
bioinformatics background
including biology and biomedical studies
majors
as well as faculty interested in
bioinformatics data science and
biomedical research
the goal of the omics logic programs is
to provide training
in bioinformatics enabling independent
research guided by mentors
and peer developing a
growing community with shared passion
for data-driven research and
appreciation
of citizen science enabling students
clinicians and faculty of all
backgrounds to develop
novel and independent research using
latest technology
in life and data sciences
the program is designed to offer an
introduction to statistical analysis and
machine learning and a broad overview of
technologies and project examples
to learn about and develop practical
data science skills using user-friendly
cloud technologies as well as r and
python coding
so who is this program for this program
is designed for students starting from
the undergraduate level to faculty and
researchers
from both biology and clinician
backgrounds
who can participate to learn more about
data science and biomedical research
and as i see from the chats today and
from the board there are a lot of
uh faculty a lot of researchers as well
as students who have joined us for this
webinar
now let me introduce you to your mentors
in the upcoming omics logic program you
will have the opportunity
to interact and collaborate with an
international team of experts
am i not audible no you're audible
website i think
some people have trouble connecting to
audio
okay thank you so much elia
so in the upcoming omics logic program
as i was saying you will have the
opportunity to interact and collaborate
with our international team of
experts who are specialized in the
application of data science to
biological data
sets so let me introduce you to the main
speakers of today's session
we have dr harpreet kaur who is a
certified
omics logic trainer and expert
bioinformatician and will guide the
hands-on sessions and assist
participants with
projects and analysis during
the program her area of specialization
is cancer genomics and machine learning
dr mohit mazundar is our omits logic
project mentor
and an expert in big data computational
analysis
dr mazumdar has a phd in computational
biology and over 10 years of experience
working with
industry and academia elia protski
pine budget co-founder and ceo in his
current role has
extensive experience working together
with industrial
academic partners that are applying
multi-omics integration
and info bioinformatics to a variety of
biotechnology and clinical applications
i would now like to invite elia to talk
about the
increasing significance of data science
in biomedical research and introduce you
to the types of challenges we will be
addressing
in this upcoming program over to you
elia
thank you bibsap and thank you everyone
for joining so first of all
i wanted to share the polling results so
that we can look
at the data so we see here that many of
you
have either a masters or a phd
in various domains and i think this is
especially
going to be important as we're going to
be speaking about
data science which includes some
specialization in
a particular domain so we'll talk about
that in a second
and secondly in the third question you
can see that
many of you are interested in
bioinformatics so we'll kind of start
from there we'll talk about the
relationship between data science and
bioinformatics what's new what's
different and how those two domains
relate to each other
but also many of you have already a
specialization in biotechnology cell
molecular biology
and other biomedical research domains so
i think that's very important
and as many of you are expecting to
learn about
data science in this webinar i think
what we are trying to do
is balance an informational webinar that
will give you a broad
perspective on data science in
application to biomedical
data but also to introduce you to a lot
of
tools and resources that you can
leverage on your own
between now and when the program
actually starts
and i'll go through some of those
examples in my presentation but then
when i pass it on to
other co-presenters i will i'm sure that
they will share
a lot more technical detail okay so
let's start i'm going to
close the poll and share my screen
so let's get started what is
data science data science
which is what this webinar is dedicated
to is really a convergence
of data or data management and
manipulation
sometimes referred to as wrangling or
data handling effectiveness
analytical methods for hypothesis
testing and statistical inference
and some kind a specialization domain
so that domain could be biological
research finance marketing clinical
business internet of things a number of
different things and so typically when
people say
data science they apply data
manipulation
and data management technologies and
statistical inference
to a variety of different domains so in
a lot of senses
data science is broad and then
we can compare this to bioinformatics
bioinformatics
is essentially the same thing because
when we speak about informatics it's an
older term
that rose to prominence in maybe the 80s
and the 90s
when information technologies was really
the key term and so
when we speak about data management
essentially that's information
technologies
and statistical inference including
analytical methods and machine learning
all fall under the same domain of using
data analytics to gain insights into
some
phenomena but specifically
bioinformatics is focused on biological
phenomena
and in today's world the biological data
has been tremendously changing so let's
see how has this data been changing
well one of the emerging trends after
the emergence of high throughput
technologies that have
started originating in the biomedical
research domain from the human genome
project is the emergence of big data
and we're not just talking about big
data files
that are maybe instead of megabytes now
or gigabytes and size
now we're talking about a whole stream
of data
that is increasingly complex because
a single phenomena is being
characterized
by multiple types of data and those
data are speaking about the same thing
from
different types of data perspectives so
when we speak about the nature of this
data i think it's very clear
especially in this latest pandemic that
not only has this data changed in size
changed in type it also is increasingly
real time and so i think we're entering
a
time when biomedical research data
from being a an expensive high commodity
and high value experimentation into
an ordinary stream of data that will
completely overwhelm
our ability to extract insights if
many of us who are not experts in data
science already in
bioinformatics already cannot leverage
the tools and the basic skill sets to
manage effectively utilize analytics to
extract insights from this data
and also share the results of our
analysis effectively
so what kind of data is this high
throughput data
collectively this data is referred to as
onyx data
so onyx data can play a
role in a variety of things that we can
capture for example
we can talk about phenomics or the way
that
biological tissues and samples look
and what are their characteristics
including clinical characteristics
we can talk about genomics or variation
at the dna sequence level and so this
data provides us
insight into per nucleotide variation
or regions of dna that have a variation
from
the reference genome we talk about
epigenomics
where we can look at histone
modification and dna methylation
patterns throughout the genome and as a
result we can also look at gene
expression which is characterized by
abundance of different mrnas non-coding
rnas
but also alternative splicing events
which can help us differentiate between
different conditions and
sample types so one key area
that you deal with in bioinformatics is
the ability to understand what these
different omics data types
define and describe and how to utilize
effective processing tools or pipelines
to convert this data to structured data
so what you can see here
is a table this is a table of expression
but this table of expression can play a
serious
challenge can become a serious challenge
when we extract
this the reads or the sequencing digital
data
directly from high throughput
experiments and so
one of the primary ways that
bioinformatics has been different from
data science
is that includes an understanding of
what the signal
explains in terms of the molecular
features that it defines
and also in the deep understanding of
what algorithms do
in the process of extracting this
structured data
from individual digital signals that are
captured from the machines
that produce this data but today this
kind of data
is not again as i mentioned a commodity
but really a standard practice across
a variety of biomedical applications
including
biomedical clinical research where we
look at populations of patients
including molecular analysis of
different
pathogens that cause and drive disease
progression
and an understanding of how to apply
these insights
to the domain of biotechnology
biochemistry
and clinical diagnostics where
therapeutics are developed
and characterization of these phenotypes
helps us
understand clinical pathologies so what
we want to do
in this program and where we invite you
to really join for hands-on
sessions training guided by our mentors
and a variety of resources that you will
gain access to and we'll describe those
in detail in just a few minutes
is really a complete road map for
data science in application to
biomedical research data
where we will cover important topics
like finding data sets
being able to explore and visualize
these complex data sets
understand research methods as you
review publications
and gain insights and understanding and
so importantly
this is a roadmap from the very
beginning
to application and we're hoping that
many of you that maybe have
minimal understanding of what data
science is or minimal experience
practically applying bioinformatics to
these types of challenges
will be able to do this for the first
time but also for those of you that
probably
have heard about rna-seq have heard
about
metagenomic data have heard about
genomic variation
you will be able to see how combining
these technologies together
and becoming effective with data
manipulation
data wrangling effective processing of
this
large data and then analytics and
machine learning
you can really gain insights into some
of the
pressing challenges that surround us
including in
application to a variety of domains like
oncology
infective infectious diseases and
complex
conditions that might not even have a
direct
clinical application so onyx logic
is really like a map it's a map that
will take you from
where you are right now asking questions
about your current background
interest and focus into the field of
data science
where molecular data omics data
can become logically clear so that your
analytical capabilities could be applied
to extract
interesting insights from a variety of
different example
projects and so a big part of what we
provide
in this program is not just the training
on how to apply these different
omnics technologies but provides you
with curated examples
that include diagnostics and cancer
biology
look at single cell and tissue
composition as well as
microbiome and infection you'll find
this in the context of different
projects that you can get started with
and then carry on to introduce them as a
starting point for your own
research project as you develop them
throughout these programs
what we'll look at as the context of
this process of
applying data science methodology is the
process
for understanding how the data was
collecting
was collected what was the experimental
design
to then processing and cleaning and
preparing the data for an analysis
performing exploratory data analysis
where you can visualize
and mine this data for patterns and then
taking it to
data analysis stage where you have
different statistical methods
or machine learning tools which
essentially represent
a model that could be trained to provide
you with insights
into an inference so biologically
interpretable
insights that you can demonstrate and
also
share as a replicable process so that
data sharing
is effective so let's look at some of
these methods
in a little bit greater detail what we
want to cover
in this section is preparation of data
and once the data is prepared
how do we select from the many tools
that are available
out there probably many of you have
heard about or maybe even applied
with a deeper understanding of what are
some of the logical
components of these methods what
situations
to use when we apply the different
methodologies
and how to combine them together so that
we
gain insights into our data sets and can
translate that insight into a next
decision potentially about selecting the
next method of analysis
as an example we can look at gene
expression profiling
right we can look at differential gene
expression
which is a very simple example of a
statistical comparison
but we can also apply clustering
techniques to help make that data
visually more presentable
we can use principal component analysis
to explore variability between samples
but we can also design our experiment to
now
use that insight to eliminate outliers
look at very defined groups of samples
and ask
questions about what are the features
that help us understand the differences
between
samples so these are just some of the
examples that we will use
but in the greater context you will see
how bioinformatics
and big data will bring out the
important characteristics for use
in clinical and therapeutic applications
to a variety of biomedical research
problems and so we'll illustrate these
problems
using different examples to speak about
one of these examples
and give you a clear understanding of
what we mean by curated data sets
i want to pass the microphone over to dr
harpreet kaur
who has an extensive background in
genomic research and application to
cancer
specifically to to liver cancer so
dr khaor i'll pass it on to you
you
let me share my screen
so hello everyone my name is harpreet
kaur
and i have a phd in bioinformatics
my research is on biomarker discovery
for diagnosis and prognosis of liver
cancer
so what inspired me to study liver
cancer
is the its high mortality rate
and lack of precise biomarker that can
help
diagnose liver cancer at an early stage
it is considered as sixth major
malignancy in terms of incidence
and fourth in terms of mortality
worldwide
liver cancer is often at times
misdiagnosed
or detected to lead for any effective
treatment
another factor that contribute
to poor outcome of the liver cancer
patient is the frequent reoccurrence of
tumor
so with these concern in mind i have
trained number of research objectives
with my collaborators to address these
issues
using various bioinformatics techniques
for example in the first project
we used last scale transcriptomics data
to identify a diagnostic biomarker panel
for hepatocellular carcinoma which is
primary
liver malignancy so in this study
we employed nearly 30 data sets
containing nearly 4 000 sample
the lucidity transcriptomics biomarker
panel
for diagnosis and prognosis of liver
cancer
implementing various statistical
and machine learning techniques like
svm random forest navys etc
for the next part of this research
project
we use transcriptomics and methylation
data
of scc patients to scrutinize
scrutinize or mix features
that can discriminate
patients based on its stages that is
early and the latest days here we employ
tcga data of nearly 350 basin
to elucidate 51 features that
include 30 rna transcript and 21
methylation cpg sites that can
distinguish
early stage and late stage sample based
on
various bioinformatics approaches
in the third part of this project we use
transcriptomics data to scrutinize
diagnostic biomarker panel that is
specific
for chlangiocarcinoma which is
another major liver malignancy here
we employed nine data set containing
350 chlangiocarcinoma 133 adjacent
non-tumorous cholangiocarcinoma patients
and 90
scc patient samples
to scrutinize clencho carcinoma specific
transcriptomic signature implementing a
number of data mining techniques
like random forest logistic regression
extra tree
lda etc
so conclusively in this
whole study we have identified
a three-gene based biomarker for the
hcc that can discriminate scc samples
from the normal samples
and then we have elucidated three ccs
pacific signatures
that can discriminate clench your
carcinoma sample
from normal as well as sse samples
in the next part we have identified a 50
51 multi multi-ohmics features that
include 30 rna transcripts
and 21 methylation cpg site
that that can discriminate early and the
least ease
of hcc samples
so in my current role i am omics logic
bioinformatics trainer with the pan
biotic
i am assisting participants to learn
about data analysis
machine learning and visualization in
application to the last data sets
in biomedical research besides we are
designing
various research projects using publicly
available data sets
so in continuation to the liver cancer
research
here we have designed a research project
based on the multi-omics data of liver
cancer patients to find out the
molecular signatures
that are associated with the clinical
and the demographic
phenotypes of the liver cancer patients
here we explored different omics data
from the tcdl like
rna mi rna and clinical data of the
liver cancer
patients in this project
we have implemented various multi-omics
data integration
tools like snf i cluster plus
o2 pls that are in already available
on t bind for server
so here we are trying to understand how
multiomics data integration analysis can
provide us the holistic picture of this
lethal malignancy and also how they are
associated with the diverse clinical and
demographic phenotypes of the patients
like their tumor states risk factors
and gender of the patients etc
participants can explore this project
during the upcoming data science program
i am looking forward to being your
mentor in the
upcoming omics logic data science
program
now i would like pass this session to dr
mohit
who is a project mentor so
over to dr mohit and if you have any
question you can post your
questions in the chat box and we will
address those questions
okay so over to you dr mohit
thank you doctor okay let me share my
screen
hello everyone my name is mohit
and as you know by now that i'm one of
the
global representatives of pine biotech
and in my current role
i am working with undergraduate
postgraduate and phd students
uh scientists and researchers for
bioinformatics
research and training and in this
process collaborating with universities
in india and africa to provide support
in in research so i have completed my
phd in computational biology and have
been
actively working with academia and
industry to solve important research
problems
using tools and technology that suits
best for the problem
today the world is seeing the biomedic
the world is seeing biomedical data
science as a great opportunity
actually to solve some of the unanswered
questions
that require our immediate attention
so talking about big data in bio biology
so big data in biology has an important
role in shaping our understanding of
living beings
better most impacted by this change
in the is the area of genomic medicine
where it is now possible to move from
generating reference
or population level data to producing
data from
individuals right and we have been
seeing this
uh as one of the case that is ongoing
with the
with the different strains of kovite
coming in genomic
understanding and sequencing is playing
huge road
in identification of those strains and
as it is it has been like data has
always been an integral part of life
sciences
but with the availability of
computational power now
and the volume of the heterogeneity of
this data
has also increased immensely so i mean
it
complements each other in a way and to
make sense of this
large volume of data available i think
a biologist or a computational biologist
need to be able to know the processes
and the methodologies
to interpret this data and understand
the patterns
and where and that's like maybe the
biggest challenge
right now for biologists and
bioinformaticians
so if you see in this latest survey
you'll find out that
of course ai and big data have the
biggest
impact
however to understand this application
and to be able to find
information from this big data it is
sort of important to learn about the
analysis strategy
and get experience working on this real
data sets
so together with our research
collaborators from topper bioinformatics
research center
uh lsu and ucsf we have
prepared projects for you one of the
projects was highlighted by dr harpreet
as well but
which she has prepared along with our
team so this projects
will help you will take you through a
project-based approach we call
and where we take data sets from high
impact publications
and use them for practical exp exercises
so it's kind of you know difficult to
imagine exactly
what the biomedical industry will look
like in in
years time but if you can see this uh
image and you can see that
how bioinformatics has been helping
uh transforming basic sciences into
translational research projects
so there have been a lot of uh large
innovative research projects which are
ongoing one of such a research project
is international human
cell atlas initiative 10 that aims to
create comprehensive reference map of
all human cells so we are also
collecting information from devices
apps variables and implant
implantable technologies right so in
this
data science program uh we will learn
about
analysis strategies that i just
discussed and methods
by getting hands-on experience working
on real data sets
that explains these challenges in for
example precision medicine so this is an
example of precision medicine
and with this uh understanding of what
the authors have achieved and what the
data set is about
and why this publication is important in
the context of
breast cancer where they have where the
authors have collected uh
so many data sets on cell lines and have
concluded would be a journey that we
would
take you through during this program to
be able to learn about this project
itself
so it involves like several methods as i
was telling you that the data sets come
from cell lines
then we have other features like we have
the
uh the drug response so combining these
features and understanding the
application like cancer is a complex
disease right and what we have been
doing so far is to be
able to understand the disease from a
single
uh aspect yesterday we had a meeting
with one of our
interns working on uh important aspect
of
breast cancer you know classification
understanding applying machine learning
methods and we realized that the
patterns that we see
from one analysis is not sufficient to
help us understand uh you know what is
going on
so there integration of multiple data
sets
and that has been one of the key
features of today's world's
bioinformatics multi-omics integration
helps so
during our omics logic programs and in
this data science program uh
we will learn and we will be using
uh different components that are
connected together
and we will in in this way we will
combine online sessions
and we we will use self-guided study
materials
and practical assignments for this
immersive experience
that has been proven to be very
effective and we have been working with
hundreds of students and interns who are
working and doing great
uh with the projects that they are
working on and that i will be discussing
in couple of slides
so the program itself has a theoretical
materials
that you will be able to find out on
this website
so let me take you to the website and
the program page
the organization page where we will find
all these resources that are associated
with this program
all right so this is the organization
page and
this is on our educational platform and
this educational platform
is a unique platform because it
comprises of in
in itself it comprises of a classroom
and it has all the resources
that you would need to go forward and
start this
understanding of this entire uh program
using this uh different resources that
we will be discussing now
so uh the first page and i think um yeah
thank you
if you have shared the link yeah
so in the first page you will see that
there are several sections within this
uh program so you have home you have
forum
you have courses you have projects you
have syllabus
assignments and then you have resources
user projects progress events
faculty members and manage so you kind
of have a overview of
all the components here in this page so
you can start by browsing and once you
have the access you will be able to see
this that the sessions are
the upcoming sessions that will be
coming up one after another and we
this is like needed to be updated but we
also have a forum here
and where we can track and we can see
individual progress
like what i have been doing what i have
been learning what i have been finishing
so i have a specific profile similarly
each of the participants on
or or the users who register on this
part on this platform
gets an academic profile so this
academic profile or portfolio shows your
achievements that you have gained
throughout this program and can be
showcased as a profile
on your on your cv or on your
on your linkedin profile so
moving on to the next uh tab
you will see courses so these are the
courses that have been already added
that you will have access to once you
register so
you can go through these courses to
develop an understanding of how
multi-omics data
is helpful and then there are
application of
omics data by using machine learning so
transcriptomics three is about that
so where we are using supervised machine
learning and unsupervised machine
learning on a table so that table is
table of expression in this example
uh in transcriptomics so as you will see
from the courses
uh then there are projects that are the
next
stage after doing the courses because
here you are
learning about the application so uh how
this
uh these technologies
are applied uh to a specific research
so learning from project examples and
then you have the syllabus
and one of the i mean important aspect
of this program
is the interactive nature of this
program which i'll be discussing in
lot more detail later on but to tell you
about this that we kind of have a
point system that helps us uh understand
that
what have i i mean how much have i
learned throughout this process
so the platforms that you will be using
and i'll be coming to that
in the next slide that we will be using
this educational platform where you can
you are going to take courses and pro
and go through projects and at the same
time
uh we will be using a server platform
where we can run our experiments
and a coding platform where we can run
our codes so all of them are connected
here
uh in this page and you will see your
progress
and the progress of the entire group and
we will be able to see and work together
to achieve uh results that
helps us with that helps us with a
better outcome
from this program so as i was uh
promising you about
the different platforms so the next
platform that i wanted to discuss
is the tower bioinformatics uh research
platform
so let me go back to my presentation uh
and
go through the courses
how the courses actually look like so
we kind of review important
terminologies and provide a prospective
from experts on these exciting fields so
each course
has quizzes that allows you to see how
much you have
learned and assignments for hands-on
practice
so these assignments are also uh being
also helps you to understand the coding
behind this
so how practical skills help find
answers to
biological questions and as i was
telling you that this
program is project oriented uh with
real data sets uh use cases and
examples adopted from high impact
publications
so projects are extracted from relevant
publications on topics that
fit the program and student profiles so
it's kind of customizable so you can
choose
your research topic if you're interested
in infectious diseases learning about
uh biological aspects of that if you're
interested in
neurodegenerative diseases if you are
interested in learning about
agriculture the application of data
science
and big data in agriculture and
obviously we have several other examples
as well
so these are some of the data types that
you can see on
on the left and then some project
examples
and the next step after doing this like
these courses kind of
lead you into multiple projects uh
from the courses to the projects and
this
serves as a springboard into the world
of bioinformatics
so uh with this information uh let me
pass it
uh on to ms beepsha uh to talk about the
important deadlines and maybe
uh and tell you about the program
registration options
and after that i will uh i will take you
to the t by info platform
and show you how the t-band for platform
is helping us to do these
kind of research and and we will discuss
about the
other platform which is the which is the
coding platform
and how this entire uh program is
uh is going to work as a participant
point of view so over to you uh biepcha
thank you so much dr mohit
so i hope that everybody has gotten an
overview of the different resources that
you will have access to
during this program and we will be
sharing the other highlights very very
soon
now let me show you the registration
process for this program
so this is the registration link and i
will post the link
in the chat box
if you have already registered for this
webinar via the link then we have
all of your uh information
yes uh step two so we will be emailing
everyone the video recording of this
session as well so once you are in this
page
this is the pre-registration page so if
you are interested in joining the
program
you can actually register via this page
so if you go down this page let me take
you section by section
uh you will have some uh description
about the program
then the different topics that the
program will be covering
you also have the full schedule of the
program so the program is starting on
the january
on january 12th and will end on
february 11th it is a one month program
and each week we will have two sessions
at 9 am cst on these dates
for more details please fill out this
form so that you will be receiving an
email
with all the different information that
you need
to register yourself to the program and
also the other
necessary details so once you are
registered here
you can of course go ahead and check all
of these
different uh sections in this page
so once you've registered here you would
be redirected to this page so now this
is the
checkout page as you can see so in this
page all you have to do is
click on pricing or get started either
of it
will lead you here now you see we have
three options we have also explained
what are each of these three
options and what do they mean so
all of these three membership options
will give you
access to this program the only
difference
in the basic uh intermediate and
advanced is the
mentor support and the project support
that you get
so in the beginner program you will have
access to the courses that dr mohit has
shown you
access to the code playground the online
sessions
and the three asynchronous projects so
these are the
asynchronous projects that you can do
so you will have access to all of them
the intermediate program on the other
hand
gives you access to a mentor
who would be available for you during
this one month session
and you can have a one-on-one meeting
with your mentor
to discuss any questions that you may
have or
even ask any questions and clear doubts
so
this is beyond the group session so that
is the benefit of
the intermediate membership while the
advanced membership give me a moment i
think
well the advanced membership gives you
access to not just the mentor support
but also
an extended 30 days of access
to this program which means you have two
months of access to the program
for 365 usd and
the opportunity to work on a novel
project
of your own and i will be showing you
some examples of
these projects which have been developed
as part of these programs and part of
our
different other programs uh in the
recent past
so this is what the difference in the
three
membership level means but if you are a
beginner and you are just looking
forward
to start with a program and learn about
data science we definitely recommend the
beginner license to start with
for any questions you can always reach
out to me marketing
at pine dot bio with these questions
and for faculties uh or researchers who
would want to
discuss more you can reach out to dr
mohit at mohit at pine dot bio
for facilitating these programs in
universities
or for your students so
now as i promised you that i would be
talking about the different project
examples
so here is a project example you can
also take a look at this project example
later
so our project development is a
step-by-step process
where we first train everyone and then
each of these participants they can
propose their own project
and they will be developing the project
along with the help of a mentor so as
you can see that these are some of the
recent projects that were completed
in 2020 uh this is by one of our intern
and two of our other program members who
collaborated
to make this project we have other
projects as well
so these projects uh range from
different topics like
neuroscience to infectious diseases to
oncology
to even kovid right now so as you can
see there are several project examples
and these are all novel
projects that were developed by either
our research interns
or by program members and you can have a
look at all of these
different projects and watch the videos
as
uh the participants present them
so please have a look through this and
now
i would like to pass this on to elia
to take forward today's session elia
over to you
thank you vipsa so now i'm
sure that all of you are ready
to get started and so to give you a
taste of what we will be doing
during the actual program please
visit this website code.omicslogic.com
beeps if you could please post that link
and you can register here for free so
before we start the program we want you
to know what you will be
doing throughout the different sessions
that we'll be conducting
please let me know once you're
registered again this is free
registration
so you will see the landing page and you
can
log in by clicking here on get started
and creating an account so please let me
know
once you are here so that i can show you
a couple of examples
of scripting challenges that we'll be
doing in r
and in python during the program itself
okay so please let me know by putting in
the number one
once you have registered on code
omixlogic.com
um
all right thank you lydia so if you're
already in there you will see
these two courses introduction to data
science in r
and introduction to data science in
python okay
so for those of you that are registering
right now and see that a few of you
are getting registered right now you
should be able to see
some of the introductory courses here
for
data science so let's take a look first
at this course introduction to data
science
all right great thank you subdues
so as we discussed the very first step
is to actually load some data so many of
you probably already know how to load
data
but i know that for me personally when i
was getting started with r
that was one of the major challenges in
most of the tutorials you will find how
to write hello world
you will find how to do some
multiplication and addition
but if i want to take a data set that i
understand
how it was created what does it mean i
want to be able to load that data set
so to do that let's go ahead and start
by
going to this first one where you will
see
how to import data directly into a
coding session
that we will do here in just a second so
you can
go and read through this introduction
click on next
and see a few options of how to actually
load the data for example you can load a
table a txt table
you can load an excel sheet or a
spreadsheet in csv format
now let's try to do it ourselves we have
here a couple of examples
if you are doing this on your computer
and probably you'll be doing in some
kind of a developer environment
like rstudio but here we are going to do
it directly in the browser
so you can see here how you can load the
data
by adding a link a url or a path to your
data
and we have an example data set right
here so you can copy this link
paste it right here sorry paste it right
here
okay make sure that you keep the
apostrophes
and then click on run okay so you can
see
that as a result when i print df
which is what is in my object because r
is a an object-oriented language i can
print df
and it shows me what's in the table so
you have
specimen1234 and then some columns
flower tree and bird so this is some
biological data
that describes what's inside now as you
know
in excel it works a little bit
differently
so you can see here for example let's
copy this link
and put it right here one of the things
that is different about
excel is that excel can have multiple
sheets inside it so here we only have
one sheet so it's very easy
but if you have many sheets you can
start working with
multiple sheets inside your data set so
those are some of the basic things
that you want to get familiar with is
just how to load different data sets
now as we showed before many of these
data sets
are already available in a process
structured
format on ncbi
one of the things that you can use and
we'll quickly go through this example
right here
is using principle component analysis
we can understand variability
between samples how do we do that
so if you go to this third course
dimensionality reduction pcn
visualization
you can scroll through and see an
example of a gene expression table
so here you can see genes
samples these are names of different
cell lines
and here they are grouped by their
phenotype
and their phenotype is a subtype of
triple negative breast cancer
normal like basal luminol cloud
so four different subtypes you can read
more about this specific data set
click on next and now let's look about
learn a little bit about what this uh
what these different packages will do to
help us
visually explore this complex dataset
why is it complex
because we have at least 15 different
genes
each one has some pattern of up and down
regulation of that
gene and we are asking the question
how does this pattern help us understand
what these samples
are or how do they compare to each other
so there's a code breakdown that we'll
skip here for a second
but here you can see an example output
and in the example output on this
principle
component by plot you can see the
separation
of samples into multiple groups and you
can see that there are a lot of samples
there's
over 50 samples in this case now
just having black dots is not very
useful so we can add
labels but since we don't remember what
each one of these labels stands for
maybe what's useful
is to also color those samples by group
type
so now as we get to this example
we'll see how to run principal component
analysis
and how to make the most out of our
visualization and as a result
you will see here an example of what we
will produce
a three-dimensional plot with multiple
groups
colored multiple groups of samples
colored by their type
so you can see here green is basal
blue dark blue is cloudy low and pink
luminal and then light blue normally
okay so as you will see throughout this
code
it is fairly simple just like we did
when we load the data
it is very straightforward you take the
code that is already here
you can run it and you can see what the
output will look like
now as you will try you will start
seeing
different types of outputs for example
here you can see
an output of that principal component
analysis in a
two-dimensional plot by plot is what
it's called
you will see the groups are circled and
you'll also see that the variability
between samples
is calculated and placed on the x and
the y-axis
beyond the basics which is down here you
will find
additional options that such analysis
can give you
and that includes some clustering
options a better understanding
of confidence of these different groups
or how certain we are that these groups
actually separate the way that they're
described
and also some additional methods for
trying to interpret how do the
individual features or genes in this
case can help us
understand the variability that we
observe in this principle component
analysis
so this is a brief explanation of what
this data science program will actually
look like
so in this example we looked at an r
script we'll do the same
for python and we will also go
into more advanced visualization
machine learning and biological
interpretation
beyond this you will also gain access to
courses that deal with specific data
types
including genomic data metagenomic data
transcriptomic data so you will actually
be able to go
in different into different examples
understand
what this transcriptomic data describes
see the specifics of visualization and
interpretation for these different types
of data
and also get introduced to specific
projects as described in this session
so again i welcome you to join us for
this upcoming program
and i hope that this presentation gives
you a clear understanding
of what this program will provide for
you as well as
how you can try to apply these types of
methods to go into
your own area of research so again as
beeps
mentioned if you want a detailed
description
of how we will cover these topics in the
different
interactive sessions just like we did
today you can go to this page
and look through the schedule so the
program will start on january 12th
and it will continue all the way until
february 11th
after which point you will be able to
work
on an independent project as was shown
by bipsa and by
mohit so in those independent projects
what you will do is you will
learn how to find the data set on ncbi
it will be a publicly available domain
public domain data set you will then
go through the specific details of how
this data set was prepared to understand
the biological context
apply some of the methods that we have
described in
and learned throughout the sessions and
then interpret that result
now to understand what a final product
looks like
beeps has already shared the example but
i also
want to ask you to take a look
at our youtube channel where we have a
lot of examples of student
projects after they have completed their
uh training
and also join our network which is
on linkedin and on facebook so beeps if
you could please
post those links so three links
youtube channel the facebook and the
linkedin groups
and also if you could again post the
link to the data science program
registration
this is the pre-registration link and
the actual registration link is data
science.oxlogic.com
where you will find all of the details
of final registration
and now we would love to hear any
feedback or
any questions that you might have so
that we can
answer any questions or anything that
was confusing during the session
we can clarify
yes and all the links will